[Music]
and great idea is who submitted by milky
taro ooh you sound like a [ __ ]
Japanese hooker is a dessert oh my bad
oh that's funny don't worry about that
part the Nobel Peace Prize was awarded
to a group that wants to abolish nuclear
or weapons whoo these the professors
tell that to Steve
well you can give the Nobel Peace Prize
to people that want to do something
don't you have to do something or they
have been making so are they the arming
nuclear armies the nations that [ __ ]
butchered that one so okay so this
alright so this thing that worth had
exported that was awarded the Peace
Prize it's called international campaign
to abolish nuclear weapons aka I can and
so I can is it's a coalition of
nongovernmental organizations from
around 100 different countries around
the world and 100 and so this coalition
has been the driving force in prevailing
upon the world's nations to pledged to
cooperate with all relevant stakeholders
and efforts to stigmatize prohibit and
eliminate nuclear weapons and the way
they've done it is
they've already they've already had 122
of the UN member states signed this
treaty called the treaty on the
prohibition of nuclear weapons and so
122 nations already done it I just like
how all these names are pretty [ __ ]
straightforward like their coalition is
pretty buggy straightforward the
petition of a shines plug-in
straightforward you know question know
what actually is nuclear energy because
only thing I know from it is the
Simpsons and that green goop so I don't
know what nuclear energy is how it
produces energy why is it so abundant
and why is it so great I don't know what
it is like who created it what happens I
mean the I don't know I don't know what
very well either but what I do know is
when you take like an atom and then you
separate the parts there's an enormous
amount of energy that's released from
the center of it oh and we have a very
basic like it's a very surface level
understanding yeah somehow they create a
bomb out of that
yeah yeah remember I said 122 un members
baby yeah they've already signed it but
none of the nine nuclear power leaders
signed it obviously you know why because
everybody's scared it's like if I take
away my nuclear weapons who's to say
that somebody else on the underground is
it going to still produce theirs yeah
I'm [ __ ]
so I don't even have my defense up and
ready I think that when we go to war
there's only me sword battles a photo of
when the union members were signing that
treaty New York and then so I found this
interesting well these are the countries
with the biggest nuclear arsenals and
this is a number of nuclear warheads and
countries will ride in 2015 Wow France
has 300 but yeah these are how many
nuclear weapons no French yeah so these
are the nine nuclear powers of the world
so it's Russia US France China UK
Pakistan India Israel in North Korea
dude Russia has 7500 nukes those are the
ones that they report to imagine the
amount that aren't reported India has
nuclear weapons apparently north korea
has maybe 10 yeah so none of these
countries sign that treaty and they even
released the statement so it was the
u.s. the UK and France they said that
this initiative disregards the realities
of the international security
environment and so a session to the
banned treaty is incompatible with the
policy of nuclear deterrence in other
words [ __ ] that yeah and so nuclear
deterrence have been essential in
keeping the peace in Europe and North
Asia for over 70 years the US UK and
France said this and so that's the
reason why they'll never sign this it's
because having it having the nuclear
weapons is keeping the peace yeah yeah
that's what they're saying yeah so this
organization said like oh we never
expected them to sign it so we're not
tripping over that what they say what's
the point this is a good start like this
whole treaty is a good start because
we'll begin to put pressure on those
countries that do have nuclear powers in
order for them to disband their nuclear
weapon oh god no that's gonna play any
pressure and ignorance to that we even
want to know that we have that [ __ ] we
do and then like especially way out of
my mind
Trump and then you know North Korea all
this talk and all this tension and it's
like shit's getting real
though Trump is so funny dude - such a
funny man I got kind of asked my
question oh yes sorry I forgot thank you
for being waiting okay the whole time I
didn't say [ __ ] cuz that's all I've been
thinking about so I don't forget my
question earlier because he was like
question and you just kept going and you
ignored him and he was just like I have
to in order for you guys to get
information I have to be like I was
taken too long ago that's my question
now all right
how they gonna enforce this so the
people that are the 122 nations that
signed it once this treaty has been
ratified by 50 states like they're
saying that the ban on nuclear weapons
then will enter into force and then will
be binding under the international law
for all the countries that are party to
the treaty so so everyone that has
already signed it they don't even have
nuclear weapons but now that they've
sign it they've already agreed like we
will never have nuclear weapons no I
know so so okay let's say let's say I'm
America right and I lie about my 2,000
nuclear weapons and I go I know more
nuclear weapons that's true and then
everybody is like a part of it and then
I go ah guess what
I still kept it there like a police I
can't release the UN can't do damping
you know nobody can do nothing they need
a giant like country metal scanner that
can go like oh they don't really don't
have it and there's another country dude
are you still hiding somewhere maybe
they do somehow cuz then somehow we keep
finding out about North Korea's it's cuz
they say reminds me of is like these
countries that are signing this treaty
it's like that dude in the group this is
like I'm never gonna smoke leaves like
[ __ ] nobody offered you you know I mean
it doesn't matter yeah you don't mean
I know North Korea actually had nuclear
weapons I thought they kept trying to
make one but they couldn't I mean now it
seems like they're already threatening
to detonate a hydrogen bomb in the
Pacific Ocean so it's so far beyond man
it keeps destroying [ __ ] man this world
is falling apart enough as it is man
power dude [ __ ] all that [ __ ] do it just
yeah I don't get it either like the
whole like I mean I get why they have it
but then if they would detonate it we
all die like everyone will die so like
you think Joe trying to get in his
country or whatever he's like [ __ ]
I'm gonna go to war no but they will die
though like there's enough nukes in this
will destroy the world the people in
power they also have these unlike secret
underground silos and stuff that they
can crawl into a basement like 10
stories it's all them remember you guys
were you were showing us ones that were
like in the mountains and it was like
yes they do tests all the time there's
some there's a video on YouTube that
shows you like since the advent of
nuclear bombs and how many times it's
been going off all over the world they
blow them up in the oceans they blow
them up in like deserts and whatever and
then you can see the whole world just
going off and then you know it all it is
it's just it's kind of like a show of
like hey this is what we got don't [ __ ]
with us dick-measuring yeah yeah because
it's a part of in history this is the
longest I think time of peace that we've
had and it's because the nuclear weapons
it's it's it's basically keeping us away
from war guys what they're saying in
that statement those countries like for
the last since the seventies I believe
they said before that we were all in
constant warfare over seventy years I
can't do that [ __ ] you be the cook I
also think it's human nature as of now
to be like dominating and wanting to
take over in some way shape or form but
I think once we all elevate to a more
sophisticated creature then we'll start
dominating mentally or online or
different ways like not through violence
and caveman-like ways
everybody was just wealthy in this world
nobody would have problems if everyone
was poor no everybody used to be wealthy
because I can't I ain't trying to be
cool but it's like an you know humanity
like we need to be greedy a good man
I was watching his documentary on
Netflix about the pygmies
you know the pygmies they're like these
little tribes people and they solve
everything through deaths they don't
even have a word for war so there's no
violence
they're hunter-gatherers and then so
when they get into a dispute about it
like whose dog is who or whatever like
they fight with their neighbor or
whatever they just dance it off it's
like a b-boy battle Danny stop that's
great dance it away no Nina United
Nations dance-off huh the Damned you
won't be happy violence but you're only
saying I love it I love violence but I
also do not condone it yeah that violent
button and your body starts to die you
get older like it's like the last resort
last last last last last resort I think
it's a bad learned behavior hey guys
thanks for watching that last episode
did you love it I know you did but guess
what you can also follow us on our
personal social media accounts with the
links in the description box below so go
follow all of us now to watch more
videos check out up there